welcome to the show the big news over
the last 24 hours
three guilty verdicts in the killing of
george floyd by former police officer
derek shovin we covered it all live
yesterday the verdict coming right
around uh 5 p.m eastern time 4 p.m
local time central time in minnesota 10
hours of jury deliberations before
three out of three guilty verdicts i was
not expecting this
um second degree murder guilty
third-degree murder guilty and
second-degree
manslaughter guilty let's go to the
reading of the verdict
by the court
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court
fourth judicial district state of
minnesota plaintiff versus derrick
michael chovin defendant
verdict count one court file number 27
cr201264
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1 44 pm
signed juror 4 person juror number 19.
same caption verdict count 2. we the
during the above entitled matter has to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count
three second degree manslaughter
culpable negligence creating an
unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm okay and then
immediately uh the prosecution asking
for derek chovin to be handcuffed and
taken into custody pending sentencing
which we will talk about which will be
about eight weeks from now here is derek
chauvin
let out of court in handcuffs is there a
motion on behalf of the state
they would move to have the court uh
revoke the defendant's bail and remain
him into custody
pending sentencing bail is revoked bond
is discharged and the defendant is
remanded to the custody of the hennepin
county sheriff
anything further all right thank you
we're adjourned
so many different things to talk about
here
immediately of course is the question of
sentencing and
we have eight weeks until sentencing and
so we'll have more time
uh to talk about that but
the most serious of the charges
uh second-degree murder potentially
coming with
up to 12 and a half years according to
the minnesota
sentencing guidelines um the prosecution
has asked for a longer
sentence saying there were kids present
at the scene
what derek chovin did represented
particular cruelty
and that it included an abuse of
chauvin's position
of authority chauvin is 45 years old
and the sentencing will take place in
eight weeks and we will see
you there there's the possibility in
total of what would be
theoretically close to a life sentence
for derek chovin
or not and although one can make
the case that his lawyer eric nelson
failed here to secure even one not
guilty
verdict on any of the of the uh charges
um with the chocolate chip cookie
closing statement and all of this other
stuff
uh the future of derek chauvin's life
may well actually be
in the sentencing and there will be time
for that the let's talk about the
implication of these verdicts though
um is this the start of a change to the
perception
of what police officers can get away
with this is not a happy moment you know
it's not
fun for people to go to prison for
killing others
it would be better if george floyd were
alive and
uh there were many bright wingers
talking about oh the left is happy now
the left is
thrilled about what's going on it's a
celebration it's not a celebration
that someone now goes to prison it it's
the re recogn the the recognition i
guess i would say
that given the circumstances there will
be something approximating
accountability it's not even really
justice because george floyd is dead
and that's irreversible uh but we're
going to talk about
you know in in a moment there's also the
realization
that this is a weird situation where
the state of minnesota was prosecuting
someone
that the state trained in essence now i
know
you know local police departments do
their own training but it's under the
guidance and under the framework of the
state of
of minnesota so the state by prosecuting
chauvin is in a sense dealing with a
problem
it created as part of a policing culture
that they have a role in and
now i
the understand aren't involved in police
training but it's the idea of the state
and the state
here uh involved on both ends and
there's also
the statistical reality that officers
who kill people
tend to avoid prosecution or if they're
prosecuted they tend to be acquitted
since 2005 out of 140 cases of police
being
arrested and charged with murder or
manslaughter
as a result of an on-duty shooting out
of the 140 cases
97 have concluded the other 43 are still
pending so we can't say but of the 97
that concluded
there were seven murder convictions so
um when you understand that there's a
question here
of is this possibly the start to a
change
in the culture around what happens
in these cases um often they get reduced
to lesser offenses you have dismissals
and then of course you also have
acquittals and plea deals and different
things
so that is the result i did not expect
three guilty verdicts i think i was
probably leaning on
kind of a mixed verdict of some not
guilty and some guilty
guilty on all three eight weeks until
sentencing
and the next question is what if
anything does this say
about racism bigger picture let's talk
about that next
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still
open to stay afloat but covet rescue
fund is one of the few organizations
working to help
businesses reopen who have had to close
covet rescue fund crowdsources funds to
provide
grants up to one hundred thousand
dollars for these owners to create
new businesses i would implore anyone in
my audience to help covet rescue fund
in their mission by donating at
covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the
organization the founders of covid
rescue fund are big fans of the david
pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses
as we can the link is right underneath
this video